good afternoon cs19 how are you guys
doing
today okay let's try how are you guys
doing it's the end of the quarter we've
made it in fact actually that is one of
the things I want to say is at this
point you guys have worked so hard to do
those p sets the pets is the biggest
chunk of work in CS 109 uh and you guys
have done it so congratulations on
making it through this wonderful
milestone in CS 109 and if you're taking
that uh grace period then I guess you're
very close to being at that point and
just imagine as soon as you hit submit
I'm like you rock congratulations um
another quick quick announcement do you
guys know that today's the last class
it's our finals lecture this is it and
after this we go our ways of course
we'll come back together for the final
exam uh but but this is it for actually
coming to Nvidia for lecture except
there is an optional review session uh
our wonderful head ta is going to be
teaching review session it'll be uh this
Friday Friday and we're going to use the
same class time so that we can make sure
that the recordings end up so even
though this is the last regular cs19 if
you showed up on Friday you would learn
something cool or review something cool
rather okay and
today uh I have a nice little
conversation about where do I think
futures of probabilities could be going
and what do I think could be relevant
for you all what classes could you take
afterwards and then just a little bit of
reflection of where we've come from
before we jump into that any questions
about Logistics you guys found the place
where the practice final exams and then
on that note let's jump into
things so you know where are we in class
we're at this point where we have made
it through all the different parts you
know we started at the beginning with
counting we went through probability
fundamentals learned about single random
variables got into problemistic models
then got into uncertainty Theory before
we built upon that foundation and talked
about artificial
intelligence if there was one takeaway
from
today sorry to interrupt you if there's
one takeaway from today is I just want
you guys to walk out feeling oh my gosh
there's such an abundance of important
problems that I can work on you know
there's a a a whole world of wonderful
things that we can do and this is just
the beginning of your own journey and if
I had to add another learning goal today
it would just feeling that yeah actually
I worked really hard in CS 109 and the
person who works on these interesting
problems could be me and I want you guys
to all see that potential in yourselves
so that's where we'd like to go I'm
going to tell you a couple quick
vignettes uh and one of the goals of
this is just to give you a little bit of
my story of how I got into research and
working in my own little corner of
probability Theory I also wanted to tell
you that because I have a very
interesting flavor of how I do research
and it almost always starts with real
word problems that I care about but then
I still get to play in the world of
computer science research I think a lot
of people look at research and like oh
if I want to contribute to human
knowledge I just pick a problem like P
versus NP and that I go sit and I work
on it for a long time by the way you
could do that if you solve it definitely
call me uh first no I'm just
joking but for me in reality it's
actually looked quite different it often
starts with hey there's this thing I
really care about and if I solve this I
think I could do something neat in the
world oh no there's not a solution for
it great I've learned these tools could
I use these tools for this thing I care
about I have a very short vignette to
start with before we jump into a longer
story I had this problem that started
with the problem set app you know we
have a bunch of people who are writing
probability Solutions and to train Tas I
wanted to say hey we've got 300
Solutions can you give me the 10 most
representative so that the TA can just
see classic examples different ways that
people are approaching this problem so
you know we could think of it like this
you know you have 300 I didn't have time
to draw 300 dots but imagine I drew 300
dots and the goal is just choose 10 of
them that to be really formal I want the
10 that if you were to take the distance
of every other assignment to its closest
dot you'd minimize those distances the
sum of those distances uh and one thing
you're allowed to do is you can say for
any two assignments tell me how similar
they are we do have a function for that
we can take two chunks of text and talk
about how similar they are it's just
doesn't always obey the the promise that
that distance will be what we call ukan
so if you want to know the distance of
between two chunks of text you just kind
of have to call this function does the
problem make
sense we went to go do this and it turns
out to be an n s algorithm you know for
300 that's not so bad but sometimes we
want to do the same thing for classes
which have 10,000 students or code in
place has 18 million students and we
want to help them solve this same
problem and 18 million squared was not a
good time and we were thinking about
okay can we just do this faster because
we just want those 10 most represented
things like must there be a a faster
way I'm going to just choose one part of
this problem and I want to talk about
how CS 109 actually has the secret to
how you could turn this from an N squ
algorithm into o of n log n algorithm
what insane okay so here's the the
simpler version of this problem you
don't need to choose the K centroid
points just choose one choose the single
point that's closest to all the other
ones a single answer that's most
representative of everyone in CS 109
and you know one of the ways you could
do this is if you want to see if this is
the closest point to every single one
you can compare it to every other answer
if you want to know if this is the
closest to every other point you can
compare it to every other answer uh
that's going to be n
squ but here's a really really cheeky
simple little uh idea do you guys
remember earlier in class when we talked
about this problem of unknown drugs and
that you want to both understand which
one works well and you want to be most
useful for people as you go did you know
you could use that same algorithm in all
sorts of wonderful places including if
you want to figure out which assignment
is closest to each other's think of it
like this way every single candidate
assignment could be thought of as one of
your drugs wait that sounds wrong but
you understand what I mean uh each of
the solutions is a candidate for being
the closest to everybody's but my claim
is if you think problemistic you don't
have to do all the work you can think
about every time I do a comput ation
it's like a trial it's like you're going
to choose one of these candidates and
you're going to
experiment and instead of doing N
squared experiments maybe if we think
probabilistically we can get away with
doing less so like maybe you've run two
trials of this one four Trials of this
one four Trials of this one and two
trials of this one every time you run a
trial you get two distances or a
distance rather uh and after you've run
those trials you can have a belief
distribution about the average distance
and after you got belief distribution
let's say say this is your belief
distribution for the average distance
for this uh this potential candidate
this potential candidate this potential
candidate and this potential candidate
now your task is well which one do you
want to sample next and guess what you
don't have to go through all n squ
before you're like I definitely know
it's not this one and I definitely know
it's not this one maybe my next trial
could be between these two and
eventually the toms and sampling
algorithm tells you yeah we're done here
we don't really need to keep triing to
figure out which one's the best
now it seems like that would be
something that would help but like maybe
would get the wrong answer sometimes but
it turns out like if you set your
threshold to be like I want to be 99.9%
confident that you're getting the right
answer you can still get this n Square
down into o of n log n how totally dorky
is that which is like much more uh uh
much more csy than a lot of my research
but I don't know maybe I just wanted to
tell you the story of like cared about
this problem we learned about something
in cs19 I happen to be teaching CS 109
when I was caring about this problem we
just talked about about Thompson
sampling um and there's all sorts of
problems where just if you just use
Thompson sampling it's better Thompson
sampling falls under a bit Cate bigger
category of multi-arm Bandits it's a
very fancy way of talking about what we
learned in cs19 but there's just all
these algorithms where the inner loop
would just be way better if you thought
a little bit smarter under uncertainty
why I think that's interesting to say
because like hey you guys could have
done this like if you'd seen this
algorithm and You' just thought I wonder
if we took some probability Theory this
is totally in the realm of what somebody
in CS 109 could do which is pretty cool
and the other thing is do you guys ever
feel like all the problems must be
solved like everyone must have solved
all the problems and we're just left
with P versus NP and that's 100% not the
case there's all these problems that
people just don't know are out there uh
and I just happen to Sol stumble into
this one because we wanted to be
clustering people's Solutions in the
problem set up okay so I'd like to tell
you some more vignettes uh and I'd tell
you you a little bit about my research
this seems like a good chance to tell
you about some of the things that I do
um and when I tell you about some of
this research I want to talk about some
of the themes that you might see showing
up one of the themes you might see
showing up is hey we talked a little
about deep learning that was very
exciting but I also want to think a
little bit about the theme of
probalistic modeling uh and then one of
the themes in CS 109 that's kind of
interesting is when do you represent
things as single numbers and when do you
represent things as random variables or
if you want to use different
terminologies distributions versus Point
estimates you guys want to go on this
little journey our last little
journey well let's do it okay um and as
I told you I'm going to now tell you
maybe the the broader thrust of my
research but you'll see that that little
vignette I gave you is really emblematic
of how I've found all these problems
that I thought were interesting to work
on that you could have found and you
could do cool things too uh and a lot of
it for me always starts with application
and then ends up to some cool Theory
thing there is one application I care so
much about like if in my life I could
move the needle a little bit in this
application I'd feel so good and it's
this quality education Gap that exists
in our world you know there's all sorts
of people who don't even get access to
education but if you throw in like
quality education the sorts of wonderful
learning experiences that we've all had
access to how great would it be if like
everyone in the world could have as
great an educational background if they
so choose uh and you can tell that story
in terms of like traditional statistics
like who gets to go to university but
you can also tell the story of like you
know people who want to get retrained uh
because they want to find new jobs uh
and even specifically you could talk
about the story within the world of
computer science uh there's so many
Learners out there who would love to get
access to the ability to learn things
there's all sorts of reasons to believe
that we might be able to move the needle
uh people have access to technology that
didn't exist before uh as you may guess
like you know certainly more than half
of the world has access to a smartphone
and that number is growing pretty
quickly so as we have technology in
people's hands can we actually move this
needle we also have other reasons to be
excited that maybe we'll be able to move
it is the data we've got is pretty
unprecedented um there is places like
code.org where a bunch of people are
learning to program and to give you a
sense of that here's a little picture of
all the K12 students so between
kindergarten and Senior year students uh
in high school or in in the United
States and this is the fraction who have
tried code.org a huge amount of people
um and by the Numbers they've had 42
million unique enrolled students from
180 uh countries uh and they have half a
billion hour of code sessions uh and a
much smaller number of papers published
with our lab but this is a very
interesting amount of data like could we
actually learn wonderful things about
the learning process from this data I
don't know but that would be pretty cool
um and then the final reason to feel
some hope is there's tools that exist
now that didn't exist for the thousands
of years that people have cared about
education well maybe they cared for it
about it for even 2,000 years uh but in
those years they did not have access to
some of the things we have like you know
when I was your age speech recognition
wasn't possible I was told it was an
unsolvable problem I wouldn't see the
solution in my academic Lifetime and now
we have it all in our phones uh so we
have this very wonderful intersection
we've still have the clear societal need
we have all sorts of new data sets uh
and we have this this Renaissance of
great ideas and new tools that exist
there and my hope is that somewhere in
this mix we'll actually be able to move
the needle that would be so
neat there is one problem that's been
pretty sticky for me you I've been a
teacher for a long time I was also a ta
uh my parents are teachers man like
education is like the family business I
suppose and it hang out with teachers
enough and they'll start complaining
about grading because it's a lot of work
and one of the ways of telling the
stories of how maybe we could make a
small Improvement on high quality
education maybe we could help teachers
by improving our assistance when they're
trying to give feedback feedback is
important but it's very very labor
intensive we could talk about this story
of let's give feedback in lots of
different domains maybe it's middle
school math maybe it's people learning
how to program maybe it's people who
learning how to program cool things like
pyramids um
this is really random but the US
government publishes all the immigration
tests which is very very strange but you
know it's public data so it could be
like people trying to uh pass the US
citizenship test um or maybe it's like
somebody who's just doing some open play
in all these domains students produce
wonderful work but it's easy to produce
that work and hard for teachers to give
feedback chapter zero in our story is
going to be like oh man when I was a PhD
student and I was just starting simple
uh we I you know I found a friend who
worked at this startup at the time
called Con Academy and he said they have
this problem they see students but they
based on their history they'd like to be
able to understand the students better
but they said they had trouble doing
this so they gave us a big data set
we're like okay can we try and
understand people a little bit better so
we would take their past we built a
little bit of a machine learning model
and we' try and predict their future we
built a model that got pretty good at
this it's an old problem hey this is me
when I was a baby and this is when the
problem was first posed people have been
thinking about it for a long time but
since I had access to these new deep
learning tools we could do a really cool
job of modeling it we built a big neural
network first one for education and it
worked pretty well we were able to
predict uh student Futures you want to
be high on this graph uh way better than
their baseline or even kind of the the
Forefront of what people were doing at
that
time we then took our model we're like
hey can you tell us about 8th grade math
and it figure out all these cool things
it said here's how eth grade math is uh
set up this is like you have to figure
out how to solve the x axis of an
equation before you can figure out
solving y but the slope is the center
point of all these Concepts uh and is a
good time and then we started to do cool
things like can we do optimal teaching
and by Optimal teaching I'm like can we
figure out exactly what you know and
what you need to learn next so like
based on your past I'm like you
definitely need to work on uh figuring
out square roots uh and there's reason
to believe that if you could understand
students and you can make good decisions
under uncertainty for students we could
get people to know more faster and this
was fine but it's chapter zero for a
reason I have a baby now I didn't at the
time but at the time I could imagine
having a baby and I thought when I do
have a baby and she leaves in the future
of Education I don't want her to solve
just simple correct or incorrect
problems uh
and that is exciting you know I want her
to be doing more open-ended work I want
her to be engaging with exciting
thought-provoking problems not just you
know solve this uh multiple choice
question now while that's what I want it
turns out it's a lot harder to be able
to understand students in open-ended
domains like for example you'd imagine
coding when you're writing a few lines
of code it can't be that hard to give
feedback but it turns out it's
tragically hard and if you go to some of
the like the best coding learning
experience online um they'll tell you
things like uh all they can tell you is
you're missing a line that I know is in
the solution and it's just not the sort
of deep feedback that we
want so we're like okay let's work on
that problem and to pose a little
formally the problem looks like this
imagine you have a task of students
working on imagine you have the
student's work itself can you fill in a
rubric and that rubric is a bunch of
bullying decisions about what feedback
to give the student I was like okay that
sounds fun let's jump in it uh we had a
bunch of Stanford Tas label this for a
whole a whole bunch of submissions uh
from 106a and code in
place we learned a bunch of things from
looking at this problem first of all
can't we just use some core conditional
probabilities turns out you can but you
know this F1 score which is a measure of
how well you're doing you don't get that
much lift on F1 score this is what
humans look on that measure of how good
you are at filling these rubrics humans
are great and conditional probability is
just not that good
good well deep learning is just got to
be the solution to everything right so
we have all this data from code.org can
we just use some deep learning I also
wondered can we use some Dynamic
analysis you know actually one of the
fun little sites we went on to is how
creative can we
get what if we didn't just look at the
code what if we looked at something more
interesting do you guys want to just
have a Moment of Zen and appreciate half
a million people learning to code their
very first program prog and watch it
visualized uh in this graph can you guys
see this can you see there's a pink dot
okay that pink dot is students and see
that big circle the big circle means
half a million students all these pink
dot students are starting with blank
code and they're trying to write a
feline program here is the solution so
you can imagine they're trying to get to
that bottom right corner uh can you guys
see these little black dots maybe not
can
you yes it's like the distribution of
yeses goes from pretty high to like a
little bit um anyways there's these
black dots which are intermediate
work let's watch them go this is a dance
of half a million people trying to write
a FIV line program most people do pretty
similar thing first but then you have
the first splits and this big groups
kind of making a good progression but
like uhoh those guys are going the wrong
way and the people go the wrong way are
very likely to then go even more wrong
ways now at this point we've got our
first group of students making it Yay
good job you solved the problem um but
then you're you're left with you know
couple hundred million people who are
still trying to write that five line
program there's a bunch of things to
take away from this certainly the
observation that people who make
mistakes are more likely to make more
and more mistakes and the other thing is
a moment of
appreciation can you appreciate that
struggle and that grit like some people
in this data SP spent more than 12
active hours of work just trying to
write a FIV line program the feline
program I will tell you has no Loops is
move turn left move turn right
move that is hard for people and they
did not give up like so yes respect to
you guys all of you guys have our total
respect and these people these people
are like I've been working on this
feline program for like three hours and
I just made it like little tears are
welling up in their eyes and they're
feeling like I can do it but maybe
there's something in this process of how
people solve the problems that can help
us
out so we can jump into this we can can
say we can jump into every single
student who's written move move turn
left and maybe there's some temporal
Dynamics for students who have written
that program that tells us what they
should do next so can you guys give some
feedback here student has written move
move uhoh that second move crashes turn
left what would you want them to do next
would you want them to do move turn left
turn the T nothing to a turn right or
add another move forward
afterwards who wants this one yeah
that's like the nice teacher of us who
wants this one some people just want to
watch the world
burn so we kind of have this idea that
yeah yeah they should they have a bug
they should get rid of the bug if you
look at what people like we have you
know millions of people who have made
this exact mistake most people who make
this mistake go on to try this
next so it turns out the crowd's a
little bit unwise so if we want to get
into probability we have to think a
little bit more deep than just can we
use conditional probabilities one of the
things we thought about at the time was
like well traditional conditional
probability asks condition on somebody
making this mistake what do they do next
but I don't want to condition on
condition on them making the mistake
because that's all the people who are
having misconceptions I would like to be
able to ask a conditional question
conditioned on the average student and
So based on that we came up with this
idea of like how could we model what the
average student does we said well for
the average student you can imagine all
the submissions coming at you as a pan
process from how appealing it is to the
average student and based on this we
could say like the expectation of the
length of their path will be the sum of
one of the expectation of their pan and
so you end up with this like pan minimal
path that could give you an idea of what
the average student would do next from a
current state it for any state you can
ask what is the pan minimal path next
and it gave this really nice problem
solving pa uh path and it worked so well
for six line programs like with this
really cool probability Theory it was
really neat we got to title something
the paston common path which felt badass
what a flex uh but it didn't work really
well for problems after six um okay so
now it's time to go back to the drawing
board at this point I had convinced my
PD adviser that deep learning was not a
fad and like he finally gave me the
green light to go try this deep learning
thing and we tried the Deep learning
thing tldr it didn't work but we did try
a whole bunch of really cool things
first we started a regular neural
network didn't work then we're like no
our neural network needs to be way
fancier so we made hierarchal St neural
networks we'd take code put it as a tree
and we had tree-shaped neural network so
you have like a neural network for each
node and they would merge together into
a new naral network for like the
compound node it was so cool but didn't
work that well so then we tried this
other thing we're like Wella what if we
got Triplets of code like I can take all
of 106a and I can I can mine oh millions
and millions of these triplets where you
have the precondition the code and the
post condition itself I got lots and
lots of these and I'm going to make a
neural network that can take a
preconditioned code and predict the
postc condition is going to be fantastic
seemed like a really good idea so we
would take a neural network which would
encode the
precondition uh put it through a neural
networks which would translate into
encoded post condition then decode it
and then it would give us the post
condition and we trained this and it
felt awesome and we managed to P write a
paper but it was basically useless going
back to this chart of like how we're
doing at grading all of this effort and
we made some progress but it just was
very far shy Far Cry for humans I went
to Percy leang I'm like Percy you know
all the neural networks what can we do
here and we worked together and we tried
to figure out and we still couldn't make
progress
so you know there's another problem here
we wanted to be able to give this
feedback but for most teachers you don't
even get to look at a huge labeled data
set you kind of have to give feedback
for the very first time you give the
assignment so you really want what we
call One-Shot learning like as soon as
you give an assignment the first student
to hand it back to you you should be
able to grade so uh we needed that and
we need to be able to verify like deep
learning is really cute and it just
makes predictions but you guys have been
writing problems at six like would you
trust all these predictions like I don't
know like I don't know why I should
trust these things they're giving me
probabilities but it could be making
mistakes it's not verifiable you can't
prove for sure that someone's deserving
the grade that they
got so we went back to the world of
probability we tried to understand why
is this problem so hard do you guys want
to know the cool thing we discovered all
of student work follows the same
probably distribution not just some of
it not just code not just essays not
just poems not just partial Solutions
all of it falls the same probably
distribution called a zifan distribution
and what that means zian distributions
on the ranking like the the prop the
popularity of like the most common
solution and the popularity of the
second most common solution so if you
take the most common solution this is
how probable it is if you take the
second most common solution this is how
probable it is and every single
educational data set that I ever got my
hands on when I looked at the log of the
rank and the log of the probabilities
you always saw the straight line which
led to this probability density function
which comes from zif distribution whoa
that's cool it's like the fattest tail
distribution you can ever imagine by fat
tail distribution I mean like there's a
lot of probability far away from the
mean so this is the most probable
solution it has a probably like this if
I didn't do in log log space you know
what this thing looks
like it just goes on forever this tail
is incredibly large and it just
basically says yeah the the most common
solution is probable and everything else
looks incredibly unlikely and you guys
know this is like the the this maybe
there's one solution that lots of people
come up with but as soon as you're doing
something other than the solution you're
in that really really really long tail
uh uh so that makes it a hard problem
and there's also this other problem is
you know when we cluster Solutions there
is this sharpness which is like two
solutions could be really really similar
in how they look in their text but mean
really really different things like you
might just be a couple characters way
from the right answer and there's a big
difference between those two things so
for those two reasons it's hard oh long
story short yeah they're all as if want
to learn more about it talk to this guy
Okay so
are we just
done no back to the drawing board don't
give up we really want to be able to
make progress on this problem I was
inspired by this paper there was this
wonderful paper I told you guys about in
the very first class and the reason I
told you about is because it was so
inspirational to me the inspirational
idea was there's this algorithm that can
learn from a single example most deep
learning you show it 100,000 examples
and then it can learn a symbol but this
one the very first time you showed a
symbol it could learn to recognize other
instances of that symbol wow how amazing
it did not just for symbols but also for
object recognitions it could do all
these onot learning
problems uh and this is how it worked
they did not use deep learning they used
beian models instead and the idea was
they took a lot of examples of
characters and they Ed it to
algorithmically create a basian program
you know like one of our Bay Nets and
the bayet would describe the generative
story of where characters came from it's
like hey you want to know where this
comes from pal well it starts with some
primitive shapes those get put together
into subp Parts those subp parts get
connected and there's some random
variable controlling the connection each
of these things is defined you know the
probability conditioned on its parents
just like in our BAS Nets and they would
have Productions at the end that would
actually be characters and then if you
wanted to take a character and predict
they would infer into the baset using
some pretty reasonable inference
techniques not too different from what
we did okay I'm going to skip some of
these things oh there is some neatness
to this not only could you predict but
you could also generate you can say like
give me more examples of this and the
very poor handwriting algorithm would
give you more examples so it could do
more than just prediction which I also
thought was quite cool but really the
big takeaway was this they had people
try and do the classification task and
people are awesome in this case you want
to be low in error rate people did a
really great job deep learning was doing
an okay job and some of the most modern
models were being pretty effective but
this beijan network did way better than
the Deep learning and even did better
than humans which is very very
impressive on this task and I read this
and I was a little
jealous happened but I was also a little
bit inspired I was like what if we made
a beig network of how humans think about
their 10line programs and so we
did and here's the really interesting
insight about a beijan network if I
could put into the language that we've
learned here's what grading is written
as a probabilistic inference
task you have a couple random variables
one thing you have a random variable for
is the code itself so let's say this is
representing the code and over here
you're trying to predict like maybe
their ability and maybe the choices that
they made when they were writing this
code because if I can look at your code
and and guess the choices you made I can
give feedback on the choices be like oh
yeah that choice to use recursion bad
call um and you know maybe at the end of
the day if I'm doing grading I might
want to get a score out of this and it
just turns out this is a very hard
probability problem to solve even for
humans I see your code and I have to
infer choices that is very
difficult but the Insight that really
came from this paper is that the reverse
conditional probability is a lot easier
for humans if I tell you here's all the
choices somebody has
made what could their code look like
that is the reverse condition and that
is pretty reasonable for humans so uh in
this case you know we have
the student
ability um we have their choices and you
have a resulting python code and we made
a generative model which says Okay first
choose a student ability then based on
the ability make some choices like have
them walk through the assignment and
make some decisions do you do recursion
hopefully not but we're going to make
some choices for them and then the task
was can I write a program that would say
what could code look like given those
choices and then the simple idea is what
if we made a nice little interface so
that teachers could write this program
so they could say okay in my assignment
here's the choices I think students will
make and maybe I could write in a way
that we can explore the exponential
number of choices that they can make and
maybe could write in a way that I could
describe based on their choices what
their output could look like wrote this
nice little Library it was called idea
to text and you would write each choice
as a Class come talk to me if you want
to know the details uh but it kind of
looked like this we would say here's the
decision-making process and every time
you make a decision we'll be outputting
code that the student could be writing
and so after you're done with the
decision-making process you've got both
their choice of decisions and their
solution this code was generative do you
remember when we wrote Bas Nets and we
hit a program and you would start to see
samples a bunch of fake students I had
the same thing once we'd written this
you know slightly more complicated
basian Network we'd hit run and we start
popping out madeup students be like
here's a madeup student it made some
madeup choices and here's the
corresponding code and we could run it
not one time not 10 times not a million
times but a billion times you know
students and teachers had not too much
trouble describing this generative
decision-making process and then we
could have a fake data set with billions
of students without even having to wait
for the first student to show up um and
then you know the idea was we did some
sort of beian decision-making process or
sorry independent thing where you'd say
I'm going to make my next choice I'm
going be as independent of previous
choices as
possible um you know come talk to me if
you're curious about the details but it
was really that we just had a crazy way
for people to write the conditional
likelihood in One Direction then we did
Bas theem to figure out what choices uh
a new student had made uh and we got to
the point where we can for some code
outperform humans which was crazy to me
I thought we had given up on this
project but um you know the student who
led this thing got paper W it was a good
time uh and it turns out at this point
we're just like having a party cuz we're
like we've got this cool little beijan
code and we're going to use it on all
your homeworks uh you know we did intro
maath and stuff like that and it it was
working pretty well and this is actually
where I got to know that was such a good
time man what a party we had in 2019 um
now I will note that of course this does
hit a a ceiling um didn't work for
things Beyond 106a but before we get to
that uh you know there's a couple things
that we got to do along the way that was
quite neat like you could take students
who are learning how to draw a pyramid
and you could break down their process
and so instead of just giving feedback
to students on their final solution we
could look at how each student got from
their empty code to the the final
solution we could be like okay this
student was at stage one for a long time
and then finally jumped to the answer
whereas this student you know went back
and forth between stages and took a long
time to get to the answer um and you
know we could tell teachers hey your
students here's where they're all stuck
on as they're trying to solve problems
once we had some data and then finally
this is one of the dreams that we're
still working on is to actually be able
to provide nice feedback to student
saying like yes the pr set app says you
got the question right but let's talk
about your process of how you got to
that answer and how can I help you learn
a better process so that you're better
are able to solve future problems so
this is a dream and we're still working
on it uh but you know when we were able
to give people feedback on their process
boy did we see a huge Improvement in
both how long they would take but also
in exam scores so there's reason to
believe if you could pull this off which
I have not been able to do so far uh in
more complicated assignments we could
really really improve learning which was
remember the original goal so feedback
on process can you guys solve it please
call me first no I just go don't have to
call me first if you solve let just go
tell the world call the New York Times
first um now at this point we were
having a good time but we still knew
that there was this one challenge which
we were kind of sucked at which is in CS
106a we would give a midterm and the
midterm at this time was something that
you didn't have access to a compiler to
I think that's still the case yeah you
don't have a compiler on your 1 16a
midterm which means that people write
code but it looks a little bit more like
pseudo code it's kind of like in cs19
when we ask for code on midterm like
that code doesn't run uh and we're still
giving you a good feedback based on that
and we really had trouble giving
feedback on 106a midterms and to give
you an idea of what it looks like to
Greater 16a midterm you have like the
question that they solve the code that
they wrote and a rubric and it's just
the code doesn't run but it turns out we
managed to pull this off and this time
we didn't get into the New York Times
and the idea was you know on this task
humans are again quite good not perfect
though we know that regrade request wof
uh but deep learning at this point
really wasn't helping even deep learning
from 2020 when we applied all our cool
basian things wasn't getting us very far
when you got to this level of
complexity and so we're like can't give
up just got to try something new and I
guess that's part of it we just never
stop trying things uh and the good idea
here
is why grade one exam when you could
grade all the exams we always tried to
solve one problem at a time we'd be like
we're going to take this one problem
we've got 700 Solutions let's do just
try and make a model just for this
problem that's point we're like that's
not enough let's try and write something
that can generally solve grading for any
problem which sounds harder but it turns
out by doing this harder thing it
actually became easier so we built a
grading system which took in three
inputs okay give me the student answer
obviously I'm grading that but tell me
which question they were grading and
tell me the rubric you want me to fill
in and then I'll make my decisions I'll
understand the student and then I'll
make my decisions based off of that and
boy did we write a neural network it was
like the heftiest little neural network
ever cuz that neural network is taking
in like over here it's got the question
embedding so we'd take the question like
write a Python program some questions
are easier than others we'd put it
through a neural network which ended up
with a set of neurons which we call a
vector we took the rubric which is like
uses proper syntax put that through its
own neural network which ended up with a
set of activated neurons took both of
those things and combined it with this
other neur Network that's kind of the
same stru this is the same structure as
what GPT does obviously not like GPT
chat in terms of its capacity because it
don't have a billion dollars of training
but we use the same architecture cute um
and we take the student solution
sequence and you put those three vectors
together to try and end up with a
prediction for how the student would do
on this
rubric and it
worked and we gave it to students and
code in place we're like there's a lot
of you and we're like hey who wants to
take a cs1 6A midterm and like 4,000 of
are like sure it's not for grade so like
a lot of people are like no I don't want
to take a midterm but 4,000 are like
yeah I want to take a midterm we're like
we can't grade you they're like that's
fine we'll just take the midterm anyway
so they did the midterm uh this is the
people who took the midterm and then
we're like hey surprise we could give
you feedback but a lot of that feedback
is going to come from an AI but some of
it will come from a human uh and so he
gave feedback to 3,500 students 10% came
from humans 90% came from AI we didn't
tell them what the feedback came from
they we just to be like here's your
code here's the feedback that we came up
with by the way we just predicted a
rubric and then we wrote really fancy
text to go with the rubrics and then we
did a little bit of cute derivatives we
said what is the derivative of your
change in your belief of this
conditioned on each character and then
we could highlight that this is what led
to my prediction and we gave it to
students and we let them do a thumbs up
was this helpful or a thumbs down no it
wasn't helpful uh and student students
agreed with AI feedback slightly more
with the human feedback we didn't just
ask students we also asked teachers we
did all of our fairness analysis to make
sure it worked for different uh
demographics uh and yeah it was a good
time what a Vibe
um okay and we think it it it nicely we
didn't have to get too deep into ethics
because it seems the model both
satisfied um parody as well as
calibration which was lucky it didn't
mean we had to make a hard tradeoff
okay and that's just one example in my
world like boy that took like a decade
of trying things and getting things
wrong but that is just one of the many
problems like when I went through this
DEC I'm like there's open problems
everywhere I think one of the great ones
is feedback for teachers so many people
are teaching and we're not getting
feedback on what is working it's not
working but for example Chile and
Colombia they both have the system of
they have recordings for all of their
teachers and they just want to be able
to take the recording and give that
teacher some automatic feedback um so
there's an interesting open problem an
interesting problem that we're still
working on that we think is really cool
is taking transcripts uh and giving
feedback to teachers so again in code in
place people taught in small groups of
10 and we had 5,000 transcripts of
teaching sessions and we're like can we
give some feedback to these teachers I
was like yeah we did we we did some
statistical analysis found times when
teachers took up student ideas we found
times when people did questions um gave
some feedback to teachers and then the
teachers who got feed
feedback asked more questions and took
up student ideas more the students who
are the recipients of this teacher
feedback recommended the class more and
found section more helpful which is a
good vibe uh one of the problems that we
still find interesting
is what if people did really exciting
programs like what if they were creative
like we didn't tell them we just said
like make a cool game and then they made
a cool game and now we have to give them
feedback you're like my grents are like
Chris why are you doing this to me can't
we keep life simple I'm like no life is
complicated and messy let's go enjoy uh
so we're building this algorithm that
can learn to play students work to try
and separate the difference between this
is wrong and doesn't show programming
Knowledge from that was super creative
and it did something that we've never
seen before uh which has been a good
time and we keep writing papers about it
though that's not yet it's it's almost
at the point where we can put in
production and we might try it this
spring but not sure
yet um more than education I think uh
one of the folks that we have started
talking to recently is the FDA cuz
they're approving drugs and you know
that problem we talked about earlier
they're still trying to figure out how
they can do their drug approval process
in a more humane way in a way that's
more appropriate and there's a bunch of
reasons that they don't do it so well
right now one is because they don't use
probabilistic sampling like come on guys
Thompson sampling has been an algorithm
for like 30 years now popular for the
last 10 at least but the other reason
that's really complicated I don't know
if you guys know this but when they do
their testing they don't do it on random
samples of people a lot of drugs are
tested on one demographic more than
another and an easy one to point to is
very few drugs are tested on women of
the age where they could possibly be be
pregnant because no one wanted to take
on that risk and so a lot of these drugs
have not been tested on a full
population and so they make really bad
predictions then in efficacy because
sometimes there are differences uh and
so trying to help them think through the
probabilities has been some interesting
ongoing conversation we've already
talked about eye test
enough but the eye test was interesting
just let me tell you one thing about it
was like what really was the ey test
about it was basically just looking at
this being and be like dude that should
be a random variable like you're telling
my vision as a number but it should be a
random variable like that's basically
the IB and so maybe if you guys were to
think about getting into research maybe
that's a nice way to start like I just
feel like I walk around the world and
everybody's just using numbers when they
should be random using random variables
and maybe you'll walk around the world
be like I'm pretty sure that's a random
variable and not a number and maybe that
could be a start of a cool little
investigation for your guys self uh oh I
forgot I wrote this up there yeah
definitely Chris I completely agreed no
one's done that though uh
so okay
um you know there's a lot of things that
AI can't do uh can't understand Lang
well wof
social science you can't really do a
good job of I can't explain why it made
the choices it do it's still struggling
to teach humans like even GPT chat like
it's very effect like quite interesting
but it's not exactly pedagogically
inspired there's a whole bunch of things
that AI can't do that maybe you could do
if you want to apply yourself so what
should you guys do next like kind of the
point of that story was to talk about
you guys not talk about me
and I really want you to feel you have
the permission to go amongst the world
and get amongst the abundance of open
wonderful problems out there I think
we're all in a little quest to find the
problems and the causes we care about I
happen to find education as my cause and
within the cause of Education I've saw
that there's abundance of wonderful
problems out there you guys will have
your own causes and your own things that
you're interested in and I wish you just
all the best on this wonderful journey
to choose those problems cuz they're all
out there they're like hidden under the
stones sometimes you look at the world
and you're like everything's been solved
but then you just take a second to stop
and look around you're like no there's
so many ways that we can do so much
better in the Society of ours now one of
the ways is just to go out there and get
amongst it some of you guys have started
that with a challenge project sometimes
you're already on this path to discovery
of a problem that calls to you and also
other things you can do is take classes
cuz that's always a good vibe too and
maybe in the classes you'll intersect
with new ideas uh that will give you
inspiration for your cause and your
problems a couple ones I want to point
out that you might find interesting you
know this class do exist one as an
undergraduate it's called decision-
making under uncertainty and it is a
grad level class but it's kind of like
the intellectual next step for CS 109
I've talk to people who' have taken it
and they're like this is so fun and you
maybe you want to wait till you've got
enough maturity to take a grad level
class but you certainly after 109 will
have the mathematical foundations uh for
this class and it's really wonderful one
of the things I'd point out about this
class and others is that it has this
great final project and they give you a
whole chunk of the quarter and say okay
take an instance where you try out
working on a problem and cause that you
care about make into a final project and
that's so wonderful and you'll get ta
support for that you can also take cs221
or cs229 those are kind of the
artificial intelligence next steps 221
is technically called artificial
intelligence 229 is called machine
learning what's the difference these
days I guess in like 229 you're not
allowed to use a bayet but in 221 you
are well I don't know I guess they are
very very similar these days but you
know 221 you'll talk about more things
uh it's a slightly bigger introduction
to artificial intelligence but they also
I think they're very similar classes
they also have this property where the
last half of the classes you guessed it
choose a project that you find inspiring
and work on it so if you took these
three classes you've had three instances
of trying a problem and finding one that
might speak to you now maybe after all
that you're like I I want to keep going
oh my God there's this class 228 called
problemistic graphical models and they
will teach you the future ban networks
and the future ban networks is wild it's
like we can combine deep learning and
beijan networks and we can learn
structures and do all these Wild Things
uh and it is a class I did take and I
would say in my life I've never taken a
class that was so hard but also I have
never taken a class that I learned so
much from and actually I'll be honest I
stumbled through it at some point I was
just like I don't know tired that
quarter I took too many units and like
at the end I was like oh my gosh and
then later I got to my PhD somehow
managed to like you know ignore that one
class that didn't go so well got into
the PHD and immediately started working
on stuff that required that class and
I'm like oh God so so then I learned it
at that point I was like I needed it so
then I I went back and I I hope that's
not everyone for CS 109 but like maybe
one day you'll need it you'll go find
that corser like oh oh I get you
Thompson sampling anyways um and then
certainly if you're just like all these
classes have the component where they're
both programming and math and I think
the programming is a good way to
solidify the math you're learning but if
you just want to go down pure math there
is a pure math path for you it's called
stats 200 uh and you get to continue
this wonderful process of learning the
math in CS 109 uh in in the more pure
math Direction what a cool place to
be now courses are a cool way to get
inspired because I think one of the
things that you learn when you have a
course is you build your tool set but if
there was a takeaway for your future I
would talk about intersectionality it's
like I happened to do my first research
project when I was in 221 I I've done
projects before and they all totally
like fizzled out but the 221 project
totally stuck and it became my first
research project so these classes will
give you space and they'll give you
techniques but the other thing that I
would encourage you to work on and and
that's kind of this quadrant between now
and then is to focus on these other ways
that you can find your own little Nook I
love this about the world we all have
different lived experiences and you know
what that means that means you have
different insights into pain points in
the world than the person next to you
we've all seen different things we know
where the world could be better and that
means you have knowledge of problems
that I don't have knowledge of problems
and that's wonderful because maybe
that's where you'll find the
intersection that speaks the most to you
in addition to your lived experiences we
all have different passions you know
like I care about education but I also
care about I don't know guitar and uh
and frisbee but maybe your passions
bring you elsewhere maybe I definitely
talk to somebody like I'm So Into ballet
choreography and ballet choreography
like I want to explore this world
problemistic I'm like wow crazy cool so
wonderful so you know you've got your
lived experience you've got your passion
sometimes data can be quite interesting
and helpful so maybe you've worked a job
um that gave you access to some data set
that's interesting and explore all these
things and keep looking for
intersections where you know when you
put a couple of these things together
it's like I went to Stanford I learned
this tool I have this leave experiment
that tells me about this problem and
because I worked as an internship that
worked on that problem I have access to
a data set you might find yourself in an
intersection where there's nobody and
there's not prior work and that's hard
because you're going to have to do
something that no one's done before but
maybe that's how you get your first step
into this wonderful world of
research okay that's what I've got you
know I I just I love it and you don't
have to all do research but I just want
you get that feeling of you're closer
than you've ever been in your life to
that that Frontier of what humans know
and that Frontier has more space to take
classes but there's also parts of this
manifold where you might be able to take
that step across the frontier and you're
closer than you possibly might
imagine the other thing I wanted to do
today is it's our last class I was
thinking about that I'm going to miss
you guys you've been a wonderful class
my God I don't think there's ever been a
class that's asked more questions in my
10 years of teaching you guys ask so
many questions you engaged you worked
hard it I will miss you guys all this
has been one of the special CS 109s for
me and so I did want to take a moment
and reflect on where we've gone and how
we got here we know about our journey
but do you guys remember the very
beginning you like came to class oh man
and I was like we're going to learn
counting and that's where we started and
we learn counting and not just you know
1 to 10 but even more we learn sorting
combinations uh putting things in
buckets we learned all these different
rules and Counting was hard um but you
know even though you guys were engaging
in a very hard thing we're trying to
also build a course Community a course
Community we like you know we appreciate
that we're all people and we're all just
trying to do the best we can this was
for me really the first quarter that
wasn't defined by Co which kind of makes
it defined by Co by being the first qu
after ago but you know this was a first
time of coming together co-president
after this crazy thing that we live
through um and you guys were both doing
this hard thing of learning counting and
also this very important work of
rebuilding Community uh and part of the
rebuilding community that we engaged
with was we did that Serendipity problem
where you figured out the probability of
running to a person we did some cool
things we made history class you guys
remember I brought in a deck of card and
we did something that no one ever done
before cuz I shuffled it seven times and
shuffling it seven times gives order
that we're pretty sure has never ever
been seen in the history of world that
happened in
class and at this point you're ready to
learn what a probability was we've just
been counting and then you're ready you
can learn probabilities and then you
know probabilities were exciting but
what was really exciting was conditional
probability because then you could infer
ideas based on evidence you collected um
did some cool things played some Monty
Hall did some prediction of a zika test
did some B theorem where we said okay
based off of a medical test result uh we
can figure out what your problem is at
in your problem set you wrote a general
solution to this which is something
quite new for CS 109 historically in CS
109 I'd make people solve single
instances of Bas theorem but in this
class I made you write the code for the
general solution I give you like any
medical test with its probabilities and
you had to figure out for any medical
test what was the probability that
somebody had disease W that's hard but
that's more General and I hope it would
my my theory was that by writing the
more General thing that you guys would
understand this more than any previous
109 and then we bummed it up a notch
we're like why do Bas theem with only
two outcomes when you can do Bas theem
with nine outcomes and you're guys like
problem set app
why uh we talked about a bull of bat man
things were starting to get a little bit
more exciting as things got more
exciting oh it's got this funny tool tip
things that's definitely not that's
definitely not
but I took a screenshot and somehow I
got the tool tips wrong but the the
important point was you know speaking of
community at this point you guys were
getting to the heftier parts of Cs 109
and the TA stepped up we did 50% more
office hours than we've done in the past
the T are like okay the students are
going to work hard we're going to work
hard too I've never seen an officeour
calendar just like every day a whole
bunch of them and that was CU you guys
you guys were awesome uh and you were
teaching these wonderful sections
actually we've had sections for a while
now but this is year three of having
sections and the sections you guys got
to practice going deeper it's like
lecture you'd hear the concept section
you go a bit deeper and after section
went a little bit deeper then on your
problem sets you would be doing it on
your
own and then time for random variables
why just have probabilities when you
could have random variables and as we
now know Chris sees random variables and
everything and I hope you too too uh we
talked about a bunch of things about
random variables like expectation and
variance then we start to learn about
classic random variables like the
binomial distribution oh and we send
bits into states that might be corrupted
good times we learned about the
geometric I love this problem oh how
brutal was this problem it's like so
simple it's like is that random or is
that not random you're like but the
geometric is one of the many paths to
figuring out that that is not random
series of heads and tails uh we use
random variables to solve all sorts of
neat problems like could we store data
on DNA um what's the probability of
having earthquakes in a certain number
of years what's the probity of extreme
weather we talked about the likelihood
involved in Bitcoin mins we talked about
representative juries in the language of
random variables we even talked about
love because sometimes Love's what it's
all about but sometimes what it's all
about is Bloom filters
and and all these problems we got to
look out through this wonderful new lens
but then we hit this problem while we
were basking in the glory of random
variables there was this hidden issue
what about things that are not discreet
like the simple humble
random function from python but then we
went there we're like okay that doesn't
scare us we're going to go and think
about probabilities in the limits we had
random variables that were continuous
and we went from probably Mass functions
to probably density functions which was
a mind trip a whole new way thinking
about random variables and it brought in
back the big old scary integrals but we
learned that integrals are loving not
scary they're our friend um and really
this class was more about finding when
you need to know the integrals than
memorizing all the rules of
integrals this took us down wonderful
paths and allowed us to explore new
random variables like the very important
gaussian random variable and of course
what do you guys get if you integrate
over probability density function
probility ah yes fantastic um and then
you guys took this and you guys solv
some cool problems like thinking about
climate sensitivity how much our Earth's
temperature could change if we double
CO2 uh we talked about PDFs you learned
about cdfs uh and then we started to
apply these random variables I love this
one and I hope the T take this into
account you guys remember this this was
exam scores for the Polish national exam
and look how gaussian that looks except
for this one part because that's what a
passing grade was and that's like this
is the nice ta they're like no way man
oh look I found a
point
okay why have one random variable one
you could have a whole bunch because so
many cool things in the real world invb
lots of random variables being random
together and we started this narrative
in the simple world of thinking about
two random variables together and we had
these joint probabilities initially
there were tables cuz they were discreet
we learned about classic multivariable
random variable types like the
multinomial and then we figured out who
wrote this Federalist paper not Hamilton
Madison and of course the exciting thing
that we worked on through this thing was
a general tool to figure out predictions
of diseases people have based on a
combination of symptoms this really huge
problemistic model that you guys work
through lots of random variables was too
exponentially hard for us to deal with
so we built a problemistic basion
network you know the idea that led to
that great paper that was so
inspirational to me uh and not only do
we build problem networks you also
learned a randomized algorithm called
rejection sampling where you could take
any problemistic random Network and you
could infer any conditional probability
you cared about which was a really
really cool probabilistic algorithm to
get to see in your first probability
class at this point we' done some cool
stuff and you guys had done some cool
stuff cuz you had been doing the hard
work at home but it was time to learn
the classics you know like some of those
beautiful ideas in probability theories
and we started with one of my
favorites we went back and we thought
hey what if I have uncertainty about
probability itself and we thought about
well let's say I flipped a coin I was
uncertain if it's true probability being
heads after I observe a certain number
of heads and tails could I rethink about
my estimation of the probability and in
the spirit of 109 that everything could
be a random variable we let probability
itself be a random variable and after
you observed nine heads and one Tails we
figured that if you thought of
probability as a random variable this is
your belief
distribution not on whether or not
you'll get heads on the next coin flip
but in the probability of heads itself
the beta distribution what a beautiful
piece of Theory and of course the
beautiful piece of theory is not just
going to live in theory land it's going
to help us and it helped us solving this
decision that we called Thompson
sampling of making decisions repeatedly
under uncertainty and as I mentioned at
the beginning of class this isn't just
something that I teach you because I'm
like yeah whatever they should know it's
something that I use and it's so helpful
and I think it could be a tool you might
be able to find applications to in
problems that people haven't thought
about and you did it you coded up
Thompson sampling you made that happen
on your problem set app
then we learned the central limit
theorem we took a couple random
variables and we add them up together
we're like What if we add up this random
variable more and more and more we
started with dice we're like okay we're
going to add dice up together and we
looked at the sum of many dice and
started to look like a gaan we're like
oh what a coincidence and then we took a
beta and we summon it up and it was a
gaan and we took things that didn't even
look like distributions we summed up
lots of samples from them and it always
end up being gaussian which led to this
crazy idea of the essential limit if you
some IID random variables it always
leads to a gaussian crazy beauty that
exists in our
world we then also learned about the
crazy beauty that is the bootstrap where
you know it's time to think about the
theories behind what scientists do when
they have to calculate P values and we
to think about distribution of
Statistics themselves and in the
craziest mind trip we were able to find
distribution of Statistics Based on data
itself using this wild wonderful idea of
a bootstrap where we would say okay
we're going to take all our data data
assume a universal probability Mass
function resample and recalculate new
probabilities and we' use this to
calculate distributions of Statistics
themselves and you use this to solve
some cool problems like hey should we
use mean or medians for Pure grading um
what's the result of a Ab test what
should we think of as its P
value at this point we've done counting
we done core fundamental probability
Theory we talked about random variables
we talked a lot about random variables
and probabilistic models and then we got
into finish our Theory it was time for
our last dance of machine
learning we learned about a bunch of
different ways of doing parameter
estimation we learned about maximum
likelihood estimation we learned about
maximum a priority and all of these
things led to different algorithms that
could do our biggest task that we ended
our final problem set on which is
classification we took three different
data sets and we used different
algorithms to classify the two algorithm
and this is still a little fresh I know
some of you guys have just finished like
3 hours ago uh you wrote leg istic
regression logistic regression that we
learned was like the core idea behind
deep learning which is what we talked
about last Friday or sorry I guess last
Friday was algorithmic
fairness and at this point you know you
learn two algorithms naive Bay and
logistic aggression you implement them
we talked about how logistic regression
was the Cornerstone behind this great
idea which was deep learning we made the
important aside say this is really
complicated tools and we have to be so
thoughtful about how they interact with
society and then we're like the world's
still changing and I we did this class
on just Monday where we said okay now
that you guys have learned all this
could we understand some of the newest
tools of our day like this tool that
came out last Thursday GPT and this tool
that's only been around for a few months
uh Dolly and how those things can use
probability Theory to generate images
and generate
text this is a little funny I did want
to bring this up I don't know if
anyone's tried this don't tell me if you
did
anyone curious like has anyone Ed these
these gpts the show hands you've tried
it out okay now put your hands down
because I don't want to know who tried
to see if he could solve their homework
problems but I did did you try I tried
okay okay but for for a class I'm
teaching was is totally legit right
that's not Honor Code problem and so I
was like hey gbt can you help me with my
homework I like hell yeah let's do that
I'll give you all your Solutions I'm
like uh oh I tried giving you all these
CS 109 problems and it couldn't solve
even the most basic ones like I started
with one of the easy ones problems at
five which is like well not that easy
boy this was a little bit hard to think
but fair six-sided dice is repeat like
no one's like that was not easy Chris uh
six-sided dice rep pulled until you get
a sum that exceeds 300 was the
probability that it took you at least 80
rules and it was so wrong it did some
things that look pretty reasonable like
it got dice right it got this uh
everything is a potato not a potato
right and then everything was wrong I
was like uh pretty sure that's wrong but
hint why don't you use the central Limon
theorem it's like oh yeah the central
Limon theorem definitely and it got the
expectation of dice right and then it
totally got the central limit theorem
wrong it gave such a convincing answer
it was so convincing but completely
wrong I think you need to understand
more to realize how it was wrong than to
solve it yourself so I just want to let
you guys know so people don't feel
tempted no I'm just joking can you guys
do me a favor class is going to be over
next we actually the problem sets are
app is basically closed can anyone see
if you can get it to solve okay study
sorry study definitely focus on your
exams you guys don't need to do that but
like if you really need distraction
which you don't you should study if you
need a distraction which you don't then
uh if could you find out if you could
get a solution to one of one of our CS
109 questions just for fun maybe over
Christmas if you're curious It's a
little little Challenge and please do
let me know because I am quite curious
um okay let's talk about CS 109 by the
numbers because I think that's kind of
interesting you know we had more than 30
major keys to help guide you uh maybe
more importantly there's a whole course
here with 64 chapters and Counting now
uh some of them Dynamic oh this personal
challenge just makes me so happy and
it's made us so happy just looking at
the the fun and wonderful ways that you
guys have been exploring probability uh
oh and this is so cute you guys my baby
started counting this quarter she can
like count to 10 I'm like oh that's what
I teach and I'm like you know tears in
my eyes been so cute so it's just been
so fun to both be a father and be your
teacher at the same time and if I could
end on a few notes the most important
one is thank you I just I appreciate you
guys thank you to our wonderful T thank
you so much thank you thank you well
you've been a wonderful new head ta uh
thank you guys to all the students yeah
for our
head
uh and then you know thank you to you
guys as a class youve just you made our
job so wonderful it turns out teaching
without students is not that fun uh and
it it is because of you that we do what
we do and that our jobs are so enjoyable
so thanks for that and if I could leave
on on one interesting note is you guys
live in interesting times and there's a
lot of excitement out there and you know
there was a moment when people were
developing all the fundamental theories
of addition and there was a time when
people were trying to figure out oh
what's a function they were defining
what algebra was and people were coming
up with ideas that we've studied to this
day and you're living in a time that has
all that movement again it's scary and
it's wild but it's also if you imagine
what it would be like to live at a time
when people like uh uh were inventing
all those core fundamental mathematics
from our future perspective that sounds
quite exciting in the future people will
think about this time and be like wow
you live in that time when people are
inventing things Chris what did you
invent I'm like uh not P ver senp like
why you missed your chance uh but what
an exciting time to be living and and I
do want you guys think there's all these
wonderful problems and you live at a
time when they're still open and how
exciting is that and you're at a
wonderful place there's so many tools
and resources and and ideas floating
around Stanford what a great time to be
learning all these things what a great
place to be I hope you guys can feel
some of that energy and and whatever
your future path
is be it going into research be it going
to further classes be it this could be
your last stop in CS and you go apply
these things into wonderful other new
Fields whatever your future path is just
know that we're so appreciative of
having you a class that we're rooting
for you on your future uh whatever that
is and then maybe I'd say don't be a
stranger you know you see coo say
hi if you see me walking around uh
please do say hi I'd really appreciate
it because you know now we're going to
go on Christmas and and we'll miss you
all okay come to the review give a great
review on Friday come to the final
definitely come to the final that'll be
next Tuesday uh and then we'll say yeah
um and then you guys all the best and I
really mean that uh don't be a stranger
have a wonderful rest of your day CS